citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for The Conjuring I know literally nothing
about this movie me neither not zip zero
zilch want to be scared excited for it I
hear that this is a Catholic thing so this
little Jew girl is going to do a really good
job with this are you a horror movie Girl
movie girly kind of more recently got into
it that's Tara Erickson you can follow her
at Tara Erickson I'm Roxy strike follow me
at roxystryer and don't forget when you are
here leave a like leave a comment subscribe
about first time in person with the Bell thing
yep it's really good I had to get her I had to
do it like basically what needs to happen is I
had to cut her off and just like throw her in it
you know quiz what's the next line of the song
ring the bell The Bell the Bell it's just Bell
it's like they do the ring the bell and then they
say Bell a lot and I just figured skip it if you
want more belle things and all the other things
then make sure that you become a patron we're
gonna be ringing your bell all day long it came
out weird it came out weird that's where we do
our entire Reaction watch along so check us out
over on patreon please if you want to be a super
sexy reject should we conjure up
some Conjuring okay let's do it
[Music] we just heard that this is based on a
true story which doesn't make it creepier at
all still trying to figure out if that's a fact
or not yeah I think Greg might have been messing
with us I don't know when you hear it you're
gonna think we're insane please from the start
Camilla got in touch with a medium we
learned from her that a seven-year-old
girl named Annabelle Higgins had died in
this apartment she wanted to live with us
by inhabiting the doll we said yes what in
the actual it plays like a comedy so far
when we came home sitting in the hallway
but we had left her in the spare room
well she was an artist a really good one
no way is this based on a true story
this feels like a recreated one of those like
TV movies that's like recreated yeah because
someone told a story one time yeah really
weirdly shot at the beginning interesting
what a wig
we made it through our first jump scare
congratulations neither of us jumped I only moved
it's like what's an inhuman spirit it's something
that's never walked the Earth in human form so
the doll was never possessed no it was used as a
conduit it wanted to get inside of you that's what
she said what are you guys well we've been called
demonologists it's one name for us but we prefer
to be known simply as Ed and Lorraine Warren there
for me good is the palest of all of the actresses
based on a true story bro there is they kept
it locked away until now shut up foreign
do you believe in any of this kind
of stuff I mean maybe ghosts like
slightly but I don't know why they don't
come to visit me have you invited them
I get my own room
do I get to pick my own room or do I have no
choice in that either well it's me [Laughter]
oh let's go oh my God is that hey come
oh no because remember they were like the
seven-year-old had to inhabit the thing oh the
dog knows the bad juju of the house yeah yeah
dogs always know they know earthquakes they know
tornadoes they know even seizures hey Mom can
I come in okay it's gonna be dark
soon it's kind of a cool runner from
the front of the house to the back of
the house I agree always a great tactic
in horror movies because you just don't
know what's gonna poke its head out okay
what is this like Marco Polo second clap
oh it must be like oh you said is it Marco
Polo yeah it must be that but like inside
a house I guess I've never played this
hide and seek clap game before all right
we'll break now aggressive Sis hey Nancy
can you go give me the matches please
what's going on Nancy broke something
shut up I feel like a flashlight what
do you see down there it's an old piano and
a whole bunch of garbage doll doll come on up
but she's gonna take the matches the doll couldn't
get her to come inside I can't leave her out there
she's all right I got her on a chain hey be
quiet place your bet does the dog live no
yes ah no it's gonna be sad and they're gonna
be mad and what's wrong said he died you left
her out there I hate it now that you mention
it I hate this movie it's actually very good
do you think maybe we could have bought a house
that has a toilet that actually works and there
was this really funky smell in my bedroom last
night like something died is it the dog no
okay I'll be up in a minute I'm gonna
see if I can get this furnace working
yeah that'd be nice it's freezing it's like
wouldn't you put a little more research into
the house that you're buying yeah like
you just discovered that room and all of
a sudden the furnace is down there like what
were you gonna do before there's a plan like
ouch I didn't do that [Music]
wrong oh don't the Bell is UN wrong
dang it Roxy called it such a
bummer oh man this this is why nope
what happened no thank you kill every human
in every movie I'm all right with it he was
gonna make it to the end of the movies he
didn't make it five minutes she really didn't
everything you see in here is either
haunted cursed or has been used in some
kind of ritualistic practice I interviewed
Patrick Wilson once he was the coolest guy
let's say is the uh Annabelle
doll here right this way
it was a good way of describing it yeah
because then you let all the souls out
evil Souls Georgiana can you take Judy
upstairs oh sure you can't go into this
room no matter what remember I think you may
write a positive article ooh a non-skeptic
I hate that size coming out stop blaming yourself
did she say stop blaming yourself yes okay so yeah
all right this is very smartly done you're doing
all those little drops the bruises the matches
the furnace not working don't blame yourself
yeah oh well written script I guess Joey King
that's her name oh came to me I could
be wrong but I think that's what it is
grabbing my foot Shut up I didn't do anything stop
fart Nancy's probably like my sister sucks
why is she waking me up to tell me I fart
and I'm grabbing her feet it's weird it's
really weird I wish I was an only child
it's not an invitation honey you don't
have to go you could just be like well
going off to bed now and 100 what I would do
yeah that was interesting anyway good night
[Music]
sleepwalking again and farting
yeah I used to sleep walk as a
kid me too it ended when I was like
18 and then I just haven't done it
since I would go downstairs and put
my underwear in the cereal boxes
oh my God
by the way that was my morning routine
what she was doing just banging your
head up against the wall maybe we should
gift that out another day 2023. she ended
up in Andrea's room to even kind
of freaked her out that's not good
girl you're my friend right yeah let's play
oh great she's talking to the doll right
who are you talking to that's a seven-year-old
that can see the maybe a friend oh really yeah
do you want to see him oh with this Dad
Birdman Music Stops the mirror standing
behind you but you have to twist the key s
up creepiest part of the movie so far no no
okay you get to ask me for three classes okay
one three I'm gonna go high now four seven
eight looking at the dolls to
see if they move they didn't
oh no oh great she's dead oh okay he's still
alive no I don't think they're gonna kill the
littlest kid this early on man then
we'd have to sit in that for a while
no no no no oh God she almost also there's rugs
this is not a safe game there's two stories to
this house there you're not understanding
that there's three with the basement
spirit is a real big fan of just
opening doors in the beginning I
while we're here hiding give me the third clap
oh that's creepy as all get up oh no
why don't I can't hear you breathing
those were like male hands
those are like big hands
off I win I wonder if the mom's actually
sick thank you stop it Nancy Nancy stops
it felt like it was just possessing her for a
second right or something the way she sat up
right like like I thought it was like pulling
her up oh great why do we even have to look
um
let's see bro you see her yeah she's
dead asleep she's right there Nancy
what there's someone 's over there
I don't think whispering's gonna help
baby I would just run at the door
smell again it's standing right behind you
not the silence bro [Applause]
talk to me that it wants my family she's a good
little actress yeah Joey King bro I'm
pretty sure she's like a gen Z staple
yeah I feel like I know her like older
but in this movie I'm like dang girl
oh my God dang girl I think
she's probably also sick
it's moving past door opening to just
like breaking pictures next thing you
know chandelier is going to fall in
mom's head for prediction why did the
other girls not just wake up from that
sound yeah how did they not like scream
who is that okay now the other girls
you just heard your mom scream who is
that somebody wake up yeah right like what's
going on mom she's nightmaring I don't know
think she's gonna get locked in there
shite well you called that one
bruises I need the girls to wake
up like yeah this is this is too it's
it's been very loud this whole time
[Music]
oh my goodness
damn another sick shot here we go
this is using the Jaws tactic we
are like halfway through this movie and
no images I want to play hide in class
so every time Dad was like what oh yeah
because the mom was always present when
he was like what's that sound I was like was
it just Mom getting beat up the entire time
oh good old night routine too that you hear
sleep with me tonight right I am not gonna not
watch that closet for the rest of this time
[Music]
I don't know is she gonna be like I'm right uh
um [Music] what that was not a doll that oh was
that the mom all messed up and that's why she was
like giant like no that's the mom oh no that's the
mom okay oh my God whether it's a Ghost spirit or
an entity and this is where the victim and it's
usually the one who's the most psychologically
vulnerable breaks the victim down leads them to
the third and final stage possession they're just
giving these lectures all over New England I guess
Northeast there's something horrible happening in
my house could you come and take a look it's
getting kind of late we really need to be hit
show The bruises oh watch she's gonna show him
and they won't be there oh they're gonna be there
you have a daughter won't you do anything
you could to protect her please can you
come and take a look of course I guess the
bruises had nothing to do with that scene
at all that's not not oh my God she's like
see how it bruises oh God where did they go
well rancid smells could indicate some type
of demonic activity well that's to keep those
doors from banging at night does he come in
threes yeah stops IT Dawn uh-huh Satan I was
here when we moved in there's also a lot
of stuff in the cellar show me the seller
picking up anything in here hun everything
everything seems an awful happened to your head
those bruises from something that happened here
that's some iron deficiency thing I have yeah but
um it all started when you moved in the house Mom
and Dad tell me that you have a friend his name
do you mind if I try to see Rory this
girl's like a little Drew Barrymore yeah
why would you want to do this
for a living great question
she didn't even know if it is for a
living what's the payment plan hey
thank you what is it
uh oh my god I've been seeing the dark entity
that haunts your house and your land [Applause]
it was latched to your back oh dang and it doesn't
matter where you go this dark vanity has latched
itself to your family and it's feeding off you it
would just be impossible sometimes when you get
haunted it's like stepping on gum you take it with
you my presence here can make things worse why and
whatever you're dealing with here isn't gonna like
us so we're gonna have our guy do some homework
on the property push her down the stairs yeah look
at all these bruises man it got your present honey
one for you and one for me oh I'll put a picture
of you and Daddy and mine I miss you and Daddy
miss you right because they're like she's
like on the road I mean they're on the road
I guess all the time it's built in 1863
by a man named Judson Sherman who was
married to a woman named Beth Sheba they had
a baby and when the baby was seven days old
Judson caught her sacrificing it in front of the
fireplace holy junk Tree by the dock climbed up
proclaimed her love to say and cursed anyone
who tried to take her land and hung herself
tree called it death was pronounced at 307
in the morning she had a boy named Rory who
mysteriously disappeared in the woods
then she killed herself in the cellar
[Music] [Applause]
all right so it's like a gang of ghosts how
much do you think it is really based on a
true story like how much of this do you feel
like they're pulling from or at least what
people might believe to be true stuff I feel like
people probably believe like 75 of this is true
what's this uh do oh and there's an instant drop
in temperature a thermostat triggers the camera
to take a picture it's cool stay at the beach
huh you should have seen Roger and the girls
I've never seen them so happy
pretty far out isn't it yeah yes groovy far
out and groovy words I miss words I still use
oh is he gonna baptize them what's in the bottle
holy water that's uh it's
water but it's holy rocks
Brad get the camera I wouldn't go touch her yeah
yeah why why can't we just like wait on it for a
second all right it's 9 18 we're headed down into
the cellar where the doors just opened on its own
I have Lorraine and officer Brad Hamilton
with me let's keep the solar light off
yeah that sounds right reasonable rational
why the sign that you want to commute
the ball this is a microphone that
he is holding close to things yeah
bounce your ball lady it doesn't always work
when you want it to yeah maybe
the camera picks something up
I'm gonna take a nap the late nights are they're
getting to me oh the house hasn't felt like this
in a long time I think the kids feel a lot safer
with you around why don't we just leave them with
you yeah like I haven't felt like this for
a long time what they have such a beautiful
family don't they You've Got To Have Some I'll
start with the Chevy did they lose their kid and
we're just seeing like ghost images I feel like
yeah it was either that flashbacks and like yeah
because like maybe it wasn't her the thing that
I thought like the exorcism having to hurt like
they probably lost a kid during that too maybe
I don't understand we've already acknowledged
that the demons on their backs and then you're
bringing them into your home it's just not yeah
no but remember he was with the
little daughter at the beginning
that was cool ah that was awesome looking
she's not sick
[Music] are you okay I'm fine you
sick I woke up just feeling a little
nauseous that's all I thought I
saw I hear Roger and the girls
okay because that's how the ghost gets in you
right they like throw up in their soul into
your mouth and now she's like haunted she is the
the weakest link that the step two or whatever
Obsession or oh the uh possession really means
a lot to us to have you here just want to say
thank you though for coming out man to man over a
car engine whatever Lorraine sees it helps people
but it also takes a toll on her a couple months
ago we were working on a case she saw something
it took a real big piece I locked herself in
didn't talk didn't eat didn't come out for eight
days what did she see I don't know and I won't
ask I got the Goosebumps I feel like maybe you
should ask yeah it feels like a husband I won't
ask I'm not gonna ask my wife how she's doing
absolutely not men I don't
know and I won't ask okay
lots of rocking chair
which brings the first stage
oh already let it inside
probably obviously right Ed it
it was a woman dressed as a mate
Ed oh my God are the flashes is
gonna keep going off now that would
be cool if it was just like picture
picture final new pictures of Cindy
trigger it what do you mean she didn't
trigger somebody's with her yeah on her back
there's someone else in there with her
that's my kid the door is
already knocked down come on yeah
she hides on top of that thing
yeah once those are locked
shut off the light
I think you're right about being on top
of the cabinet let's just look up foreign
[Music]
hides when he's afraid hon could
I have April's music box please no
is that a new Oh I thought it was
like a noose could be I do not want
to see what's on the other end of this oh
yeah oh it is okay yeah yeah makes sense
oh my gosh Vera Farmiga fell so far that
was multiple stories that was a cool shot I
wonder how they shot that it really looked like
she was like falling [Music] hooray the rain
check the seller yeah I mean she went down
so you see him and then what what's your
problem oh that's the mom over the boy
she sacrificed him but then she yeah killed her
herself slow turn no thank you absolutely not uh
[Music]
she made me do it like Annabelle
Shook on that one gracious
[Applause]
she possessed them under a child she gives us
Carolyn every night that's what the bruise marks
are she's feeding off of her the necklace is how
her kid's always with her remember yeah [Music]
uh Nancy oh God
whoa
[Music]
catcher
[Music] bomber about her hair yeah
gonna have a weird haircut for a bit
it's like a gum stuck in your hair
the footage developed and get it
over to Father Gordon I imagine
we get a pretty fast response
gotta go get your necklace bib
oh oh okay Judy oh God
I had a vision of Judy in the water I know
it was some kind of warning get the necklace
yeah man I don't know why I feel like that
matters but I do it does gave it to you so
you she could always be with you the kids aren't
baptized and the family they're not members of
the church oh come on the approval would have to
come directly from the Vatican that's so intense
I thought the church says love everyone yeah
exactly just be like yeah let's help him out
oh you saw the hand on the first one no I
did not I only saw the face in the second
here Daddy
that's very cool set design like she like matches
the wall and red stairs like
what The Shining yeah red rum
I'm gonna go in that room she's not supposed
to what if the doll is gone like out of its box
oh snap she is foreign
[Music]
Mom Dad Nana someone that dark dang
not hiding that room
oh [Music]
yeah do you want to get back
honey get back oh my goodness
Annabelle's traipsing around town man you
think she's gonna be in the case or no yes
good question she probably right she's like
well gotta get back okay still in the case
they saw the chair fly yeah
scared she's gonna hurt her kids
yeah I would be too oh wait she joke
and the little one oh okay Bad News Bears yeah
she's like full-on oh no it's Roger there's
something going on with Carol Andrew was here and
she said that Carolyn took off with Christine and
April the girl said she smells like rotten meat
oh Roger get back to the house now I'll meet you
there you think I'm gonna let you walk into this
not lose you he won't let's finish this together
somebody's not making out of this and I'm
not just talking about the dog anymore
[Music] [Applause]
I am freezing is it because this
is freezing yes oh my gosh [Music]
oh are you aware to take her to
the priest wait where's April
April oh now you can get your necklace
[Applause] whoa if we take her
out the witch will kill her
whoa
[Music]
oh my God this is Goosebumps city right here I
have to find April okay I promise where is April
[Music]
oh yeah let's get something to tie her up
[Music] the news yeah all right that's what
I was gonna say you need to leave I have to
do it the exorcism what I thought you said we
need a priest you're not a priest well you got
a better idea yeah God brought us together for
a reason yeah this is it I'm gonna get the
book what book The Bible the exorcism book
is that a book no I don't know there probably
is one right I don't know they're like number
one stop start speaking the Bible number two
throw holy water number three the end Santa wow
[Applause]
oh no
[Music]
did it just like make all the ghosts into
crows I don't know you know the birds have
been killing themselves against the window
the whole movie yeah [Applause] oh Google
how do you hook up with someone after that
you don't know you're just like
we're divorced that's it [Music]
oh my God I command you to reveal yourself tour
keep going maybe
oh okay based on a true story only
a fantasma or omnis Legion dominated
[Applause]
Do not drop her
down put her down don't say it
like that yeah but speak more Latin
[Laughter] [Music]
why is he Standing On Top of the wobbly thing
[__] him she's already gone April I thought
oh boy yeah are you sure that
nobody was even looking for her yeah
are they gonna have to kill the mom here
[Music] yeah right there [Applause] yeah
they're gonna have to kill her before she kills
her kid right that's how it's gotta go down
absolutely
wow I condemn you back to hell
don't let this thing do this you gotta fight
it I know you're stronger than serious you
gotta fight it he's so monotone right that's
it get her back remember what you showed me
you said they meant the world to you
try to get the kid out though like
don't just stand there yeah [Music] ah
Sun heals all
[Music]
he's so scared of her yeah that would suck
oh is this gonna be some callback
like the ghost hasn't left where
she's like oh she's giving her the
necklace uh I think so okay good
but I do think we didn't kill the thing
it's gonna just find a new home yeah
like this music is making us think happily
ever after but it's like for who dog
the Vatican approved the exorcism bureaucracy
I just can't read when you're there
I'm a whisper out louder I
said my bad where is he Rory
[Music]
I don't see anything in there right no
what all right look at the kids oh my God
whoa that's bizarre
whoa
goes
uh Peter saffron
Walter Hamada
it's almost like a DC movie
I want to go there to the haunted artifacts Museum
are you Gathering that these are all newspaper
real newspapers right yeah Patrick Wilson
looks like a dead ringer for her
Lily Taylor okay
shall we King baby you called it
it's a cool way to do credits
Yeah by like showing us who's
who because the based on the true
story thing modern day ghost hunting
good job with that music Joseph
I mean I'm trying to see an interview with these
real people you know yeah me too talking about it
me too that was really good very good that felt
like a you know I we see a lot of horror movies
nowadays that feel like Indie Art House or horror
movies this felt like a big massive franchise old
school horror movie yeah I agree and they didn't
like I didn't feel like the times when it could
have gotten corny felt corny it felt real to me
like I was in the I was invested most of the time
and and a lot of like horror movies there's a lot
of times where I'm like oh come on man like you
kind of see it coming and for this I I maybe it's
just because the acting was so great that made it
really believable and I was engaged the entire
time the acting was really great I was a little
nervous in the first minute and a half of this
movie when we start with those and I was like this
is kind of playing like a comedy to me and I I
felt so thrown in with the girls that were telling
the story I'm kind of surprised we didn't jump
back to those girls at all yeah they they were
an interesting window in and then we kind of just
Dip set on them which was I'm curious what the
conversations were like around that but nothing
against those actresses but just for some reason
the performances weren't like lining up for me
with what I was hoping this movie was going to be
right and then we jumped into 1971 with all of our
people with um Vera and Patrick and Ron Livingston
and Lily and all the kids and I was like oh okay
this is going to be really really good like right
when we got there I was like oh they totally
have confidence in this story in the script
yeah every aspect of it so there's a Conjuring
2 right yeah and then there's an Annabelle movie
yeah well that just came out right with the
girl that dances no no no no you're thinking
of um what's her name Megan uh never mind I think
there's a name she looks like that doll that's
why I thought that maybe there's yeah there isn't
it I don't I'm not sure what all the sequels are
of this but it makes sense that it's a franchise
because obviously they set up I love that it's a
full story but they did leave room for you could
go a thousand million directions yeah for sure I
mean not evil spirit's just floating around town
Massachusetts land yeah I mean that for sure you
could think of like who else that Spirit would
go to and also we could follow Patrick Wilson and
Vera formiga as they do this with other people or
other Spirits or different Conjuring things yeah
like in the beginning where they were shooting
where it was like maybe as soon as they cut back
to them at the University in the very beginning
and he clicks off the TV and you're like oh
thank God that's why I felt like a TV movie and
you're like oh it was his footage or whatever
um yeah that found like the found footage kind of
style yes we which I was like oh you could keep
doing that but then keep up with the style of like
yeah we're still gonna shoot it like Doper than
that yeah like the Warner shots and the totally
it was like Blair Witch for a second and then it
was like wait a second this is supposed to be
a very high budget big franchise movie I feel
yeah like you said that one shot there's a lot
of really cool like when she was falling how did
they I would have to like go back and look at it
in slow-mo to be like oh did they just replicate
her falling through one and then just like make it
seem like it kept going like because he cut away
from it and cut back to it but that shot was so
cool to me and also all the rest of it but it did
still feel very big budget even though we are just
really in one location the entire time which is
normally a great way to like save on budget it's
like a horror you're like one location awesome
um but they really knew how to play with the
environment maybe it's because we took like a
couple of breaks away from it um by going to the
other house by going to the school like just being
outside a little bit yeah totally like that gave
us a a little bit of like my I guess a breath of
fresh air and back into real life to be like
well what's actually going to happen once we
arrive back at the house like what can we learn
more being outside of it and I guess we learned
the most once their daughter was in that room and
Annabelle was not there yeah and they were like oh
so cheap free roams what is the connection to this
whole story and specifically Annabelle I guess
that was like part of the piece that is missing a
little bit for me is that we know that this house
is for lack of better words haunted we know that
there have been multiple suicides and deaths in
this Han in this house and we know the story from
the girls that Annabelle was a real person asked
to be like put in the doll right so it didn't seem
connected to the story that we were watching right
it because the story we were watching was like
they got that house and then that woman was like
I sacrificed myself to Satan and all of this land
and then kills the daughter first or whatever then
kills the son and then kills herself so maybe they
were just setting up with Annabelle the doll that
that's what they do and oh that they take over
but then member Vera farmiga's character I keep
forgetting whatever but Vera Yuga she said it
I don't know she was like they don't take over
things they take over in the very beginning she
was like they don't take over things they wanted
to get to you meaning like it took over the doll
but they it want it wanted just to get to you to
a human that's what she said to the girls which
I found very intriguing and then when you see the
doll no longer there and they're like oh is it
because it got to the daughter through the doll
which daughter her daughter or the other people's
daughter her daughter right so that's with the
doll but what did the what did Annabelle have to
do with the nothing or family I that's what I'm
I'm like I think it's maybe it's totally separate
and it was just trying to give us an Insight that
the Spirit isn't trying to go through isn't like
inhabiting a a doll or a picture frame it's using
those things to get to the humans so I guess when
we see things move that we're like oh yeah it's
trying to get to the to the girls but still I'm
with you on that I don't see the big connection
I'm sure you guys at home are like this is what
it is yeah please let us know and that's totally
fine it didn't deter it didn't distract me it
didn't depend on a movie for me but I did kept
I kept thinking when we open a closet or on top
of it or whatever we're gonna see the the doll
yeah and then the doll was never there instead it
was the music box and then at the end when Patrick
Wilson puts hit the music box in his thing I was
like oh that was the doll has nothing to do with
this family or that thing this was their thing
the whole music artifact right I wonder if they're
just doing that because they had already read both
the scripts and they're like we need to give some
juice on how these two people started their whole
paranormal activity it started all with Annabelle
and that was their very first I don't know if you
said that in the college talk he might have been
like and that was our first case and maybe that's
why they showed it and then maybe the writers were
like let's just show a little more juice because
the next one's gonna be about Annabelle I don't
know yeah because Annabelle I feel like I so
I don't know much about this going into this
I didn't know much about it I knew like I said
James Juan Patrick Wilson because I uh when I was
interviewing him for Aquaman oh yeah the both of
them who were both awesome I was like researching
what they had done together and I was like okay so
this is a team up and there was a lot of stuff in
Aquaman that was very horror-esque did you see I
did so at the beginning it's like this Lighthouse
and it's kind of got that same audio mix that
you feel like a lot of horror movies do or like
the windows are kind of slamming against it even
though it's not a horror movie at all yeah you
kind of see his imprint on it so I kind of wanted
to see where that came from even though I didn't
end up watching this movie so that had stuck with
me and other than that the only other thing that
I knew about Conjuring was this doll Annabelle
like I yeah I had known Annabelle is the doll
from Conjuring so I I maybe I just did that to
myself where I kept thinking that Annabelle was
going to be the big thing right because that's
the only thing I knew and I'm wondering why is
Annabelle so famous from this movie when she kind
of like just chilling yeah she's just chilling but
I but I thought like while I was watching it that
I'm like isn't there a house where they're like
this Annabelle doll actually exists and you
can take a tour yes okay yeah that's a real
thing yeah and I heard about that and then I
did make the assumption that this was going
to be about that especially when you open up on
the girl saying that but it's really just like
I guess it was just like oh a piece of information
but I'm still like why would they give us it's not
like related I guess she's just an overarching
like this stuff exists and people get like the
spirit dements these certain things and then
the Soul stays locked in a in an item right
and like a through line for the franchise which
probably they were already thinking about yeah
they're like well we're gonna have to maybe the
obvious is to show Annabelle in the first one
they're like we're not gonna I'm kind of glad
that they did though to be honest because you
know we've got all there's so many franchises
with the dolls right with yeah Chucky and
um just like I feel like it's a you just made
it clowning it up you mentioned Megan there's
a lot of dogs so this did differentiate itself
the music box really did work for me everything
about this was true truly scary yeah a lot
of the horror movies we watch now are that
borderline it's more like oh it's kind of creepy
this was a this is scary oh yeah I mean I I really
did get goosebumps a few times and I think what
made this movie win in a lot of moments is like
I felt emotional when the mom was like I am so
sorry and also emotional when Vera was helping her
and reaching putting her hand down being like you
don't want this remember this this moment which I
thought was a really nice callback because I felt
her being there and that being the thing that
helped like pull her out of it was like obviously
her children and her family uh and they set it up
in a way that like wasn't too over forced with
this thing we didn't have to see it a lot but
I felt it so the pacing and the tone of like the
way they brought that up made me feel something
which in other movies I'm like oh they could put
that there and try to have a call back to it and
I would feel nothing but this movie did a really
good job of balancing like what's going on it's
scary but also you feel for these people because
of what they're going through definitely I agree
with that thinking about feeling for these people
too I feel like a lot of a lot of this movie asks
you to bring your own thoughts to it in terms of
like you think about that Mom that we saw kill
her kid right yeah and for years everybody's just
thought that this mom killed her kid and like that
that's the I think like if I was a spirit you
don't move on until things are cleared up right
right and this mom everybody's thinking his mom
just murdered her kid and the mom's like I didn't
do that like I just possessed I didn't just decide
to murder my effing child you know right so maybe
that does help the spirits move on to kind of have
their families character come in and see things
that did happen and be able to like understand and
say out loud speak into the universe this is what
happened here she did yeah you know the the thing
possessed her and that's how it all went down
it's it's it's weird though because like when
when the mom says like look what you made me do
like we're seeing that she is possessed but they
tell the story sadly that something happened with
the mom and the mom was just like I give myself
over to Satan and then kills her first child as
a sacrifice and then that was still the same mom
that was like then killing the sun in the basement
right I don't know the story makes it where I feel
for her too but then I remember that they're like
oh but like she like gave herself over to Satan
her land and that's why there all these people are
like demented right but is that was that just the
origin like lady that they were speaking of and
the lady in the basement was a different woman
who is now possessed because she lives on that
land and that Spirit was there taking the latter
of God I'm gathering yes now I'm with you because
I was like is that they're telling the story
and there was multiple people multiple times
yeah and there's a lot and I think that's kind of
on purpose too where they really want this goes
back I think they mentioned the 1800s right and
then they talk about all the different families
who have lived there and they show us photos and
whatnot so so they were just telling us about the
origin woman and then the woman that we see who's
like look what she made me do which by the way I
can't stop every time I hear it it look what you
made me do the song yeah but she was like look
what she made me do and then she runs into the guy
and she says that look what she made me do and all
of that and then we watch her she's definitely
possessed she's yeah like she didn't want to
kill her kid a hundred percent is what I gathered
from that it just sucks that one woman had to ruin
it for everybody and all these people are just
like going on to the land being like we're gonna
buy a house and have a nice life and now this
lady she's like Satan come take over the land
speaking of women having to ruin it for everybody
I'm stoked this is our they've been asking for me
and you team up and we we did it I know a team
up together watching a horror movie just a bunch
of it they're just gonna make us we're going
to be the horror girl squad where do you think
that this does rank in your you told me at the
beginning that you are newer to the horror scene
like you've been more getting on it do you feel
like is this up there for you with the classics
or is it more kind of like a modern classic
for you hmm no I mean I would I would put it
I would put it up there only because I feel like
it it didn't hit like tropes that I thought was
like too corny it just hit where it was like this
is scary and creepy but also I feel like it's real
and there I feel something in the moments that I'm
supposed to which makes it like a winner for me so
I'd I'd put it like up at the top I also always
say I'm like it from 2017 top movie of that year
I love that movie so much that was the movie that
got me into horror movies really terrified to see
it but I had to watch a trailer reaction a bunch
and when I edited the trailer reaction I was like
I can watch these jump scares because I like just
watched it a lot and that convinced me to go see
the movie meanwhile I was like I'm not gonna see
it I'm just gonna react to this trailer and then I
went to go see it I'm like this movie is fantastic
and so after that I have watched horror movies
because I I was just always so scared that I would
be absolutely terrified and not be able to watch
um and like this this movie is great because
there's a lot of times in certain horror movies
uh I mean I just watched rack with Greg rack is
also a great wreck it's like Rec like recording
and it's in Spanish and that's a fantastic
horror movie as well and the reason I put
that up also at the top I'm like because I feel
something the characters are very very real and
it also happens to be like scary and spooky um
because there's a lot of times in some horror
movies where they don't get the part where I'm
like just let it breathe for a second so I can
feel for the people in the movie yeah and I I hate
that when they skip over the park because then I
don't care yeah I'm with you where I I don't come
from a horror background so I really need to be
invested in characters and premises like it's it's
not enough for me to just be scared I need there
to be something to you know hang on to yeah I feel
like this really did a great job with that this is
going to be such an obnoxious comment and I don't
know where I came up with this from but I kind of
thought this movie was going to be trash I I have
no idea how I thought that not even trash isn't
bad but trash isn't like corny cheesy like yeah
just one of those um I I don't know like shitty
bee like horror movies or something maybe maybe
I don't even know why I thought that because I
guess maybe I don't hear people talk about The
Conjuring in the conversation that they do about
these great horror movies but maybe I haven't
been talking to the right people because to me
when we were watching that I just kept being
so surprised with how awesome this movie is
in in all aspects with the sound design with the
way that it looked with the characters with the
performances yeah the way that the first two
minutes are is kind of how I thought the whole
thing was gonna go right and then when we switch
I'm just like wow that movie was phenomenal I
really hope that this franchise holds up and that
right we get to watch the next one hopefully I'll
dug this movie too and want us to watch the
next one because I I want to see Conjuring 2
after this oh yeah me too also if there is an
Annabelle which I feel like there probably is
like we got to get to that as well for sure maybe
in like it maybe in uh years from now we'll see
some kind of a Joey King spin-off of that oh later
on that would be that she's so good yeah like what
yeah it was nice to have kids in here that were
good yeah I'm like like you said like the little
girl Hermione of Drew Barrymore sort of like um
in E.T Drew Barrymore is like I will I re-watch
E.T and I'm like the fact that Drew Barrymore
is that good and she's like five I don't I don't
know how kids do it I really don't crazy and the
same for Joey King Joey King same for Joey King
I mean she's not five but she's young still
and she does a fantastic job being emotional
I believe her some might say that Joey King is a
queen some might say that we're a queen [Music]
if you want to see us do Conjuring 2 please make
sure you write that in the comments also let the
people know how much you like the team up we need
it I I have a uh a team up name with John where
Ron joxie you and I need to think so you guys let
us know all of that as well if you're not already
a patron please become one don't forget again like
comment subscribe do you do an outro bill I don't
but I'll ring the bell well as you go ring the
bell it's pretty good it was a good height now
good right and we're ending this with the patron
of the day shout out Garth McMurray my dude
I'm obsessed with Garth because he loves comic
books and he's back from the East Coast like me
and he's just a dope dude and he's an unbelievable
artist too actually well you draw stuff Garth do
you this is a crazy thing about Garth Garth will
take a um uh white or dry erase board what are
those things called yeah yeah yeah whatever
and draw like something that I couldn't draw
if I had 50 years to draw it with like a real pen
and Pad it's crazy but you know you're my guy I
always want to give you shout outs when I can so
thank you for being an awesome super sexy reach
yeah man I mean sketch us up you know send
us a sketch email it to me oh email email it
email email me a sketch Garth show me the
juice she can be a bunny because that's
their yeah I can be Spider-Man yeah bunny
bunny spiders mine's cooler thanks guys bye
this is for the sink it's my favorite
line you stole my favorite line sorry
foreign